so a cnn reporter has confronted the
woman behind the completely bogus audit
of the
arizona 2020 absentee ballots it's
everything you would imagine it to be
now as a reminder there is yet another
so-called audit happening in arizona
where um absentee ballots are being
analyzed with special cameras and
flashlights and
i don't know if it's neon or uv light
looking for everything from
uh postmarks or that aren't supposed to
be there bamboo fibers it's still
ongoing and it's completely
hair brained and it's not going to
achieve anything cnn's king law
a spoke to the arizona state senate
president republican
karen fann about the audit that's taking
place
in maricopa county it is completely and
outrageous completely and totally
outrageous and we're going to jump right
into it and check out the conversation
good morning senator fan you may not
recognize arizona senate president karen
fan
let's get this thing done she's the
elusive leader behind the notorious
so-called audit happening in maricopa
county arizona
i don't know what's legit what isn't
legit but why wouldn't we want to answer
those questions dude
we're just questioning democracy no i'm
questioning the integrity
of the election system which is the
backbone of democracy that's right
which means we should have full 100
confidence
in our democracy and in our election
system now as often happens with these
conspiracy theorists she says a karen
says
we just want to be sure everything was
clean and good
why wouldn't you want to know that ms
cnn reporter
and they are messing with the burden of
proof the immediate question to karen
has to be what reason do you have to
doubt that joe biden really won
because otherwise you're just opening up
the door to this endless never-ending
unquenchable skepticism
that can never be satisfied which is a
hallmark of many conspiracists
let's continue but you're talking about
trying to disprove
conspiracies if i have to yes why
wouldn't we
if somebody says something is out there
i would love to be able to say that's
not true guys aren't you raising more
questions by giving
rise to these conspiracy theories no
again
if someone raises something well what
about bigfoot
why isn't she devoting her time to
disproving
bigfoot why isn't she spending time
trying to
disprove that the earth is flat or that
it's spherical or whatever
the point is they conveniently reverse
the burden of proof when it suits them
and that's exactly what karen fan is
doing here check out this next clip
and look at how she again reverses it
okay
so let me ask you a question are you 100
percent confident
that every vote that came in in arizona
or any other state or
can you say emphatically 100 percent
that no
uh dead people voted that ballots
weren't filled out by other people
that the chain of custody from the
minute people's
uh voted their ballots that the chain of
custody
was accurate and and on target the
entire time can you tell me that
i can say that what the data shows us no
widespread fraud so here's the problem
when
karen fan says are you 100 sure about
x in life what is anyone ever 100
percent
sure about we talk about confidence
intervals we talk about
material significance in a country of
331 million people
will some people try to vote twice sure
yeah mostly republicans
who want to test the system and then
they get caught but some people will do
that in a country of 331 million
will a vote by steve jones jr
be wrongly counted as a vote by his
deceased
father steve jones senior sure that can
happen
it's not are you 100 sure about every
ballot because then we can never stop
auditing any election
the question is do i have any reason to
think
that whatever anecdotal irregularities
might have happened
would have had any effect on the results
of even
one state and the answer is an emphatic
no
let's look at a little more i i didn't
say there was fraud but you just said
chain of custody yeah chain accounts
people that's these things are all fraud
well
i've asked you a question can you
honestly tell me
in all the states that no ballots from
people that already deceased
were not filled out and sent in i can
tell you that what the data has shown
overwhelmingly is that elections this
was most the most
secure election in american history okay
i like some of what the reporter kyung
lai is doing here
but i would like to see her turn it
around on karen a little more
karen this isn't about me unless you
have reason to tell me there was fraud
and here's how it was done
and it would have possibly changed the
results or possibly even
uh uh changed the outcome in one state
never mind the the national results then
it's not for me to prove it
you have to prove that to me you want
the audit
not me so bring some real probable cause
here's one more clip first of all when
we talk about transparency
from day one the entire process has been
live streaming
so anybody on oan with cameras
controlled by oauth are you saying that
oan is not a credible
uh news news source are you saying that
okay i'll remember that cnn is saying
that oen is not a credible one yes okay
very good okay so there's a lot i could
say there but i'm just going to opt out
and
present that part without comment as
funny as it is it is
funny that karen seems to think that's a
gotcha moment
when the world sees that and says what
is wrong with this woman
imagine if the money that people donated
to this nonsense
instead they donated to
environmental initiatives education
eradicating child poverty like
this amount of mental energy
i guess what we would call activism and
financial contributions
would be better uh used
for almost anything than
donating to look at ballots under uv
light
and with spectrometers or whatever in
arizona from a six-month-old election
when even if you somehow managed to
prove that donald trump really won
arizona
it still would not change the overall
results of the presidential election now
more than six months in the past it is
stunning stuff and this is real money
and brain power i mean okay brain
brain brain power maybe is the wrong
word but it's real
people's time and money that could be
used to dealing with something that
actually is worth dealing with it's
pathetic and they're just not going to
stop